Escribe un binomio que exprese la diferencia entre el área de un rectángulo,
que mide "p" de largo y mide 2r
de ancho, y el área de un círculo cuyo diámetro mide 4r. Y además nos están diciendo
que "p" es más grande que 7r.
Entonces pues vamos a empezar por calcular, cuál es el área de un rectángulo que mide "p" de largo y mide
2r de ancho.
Entonces digamos que por aquí está nuestro rectángulo y que además mide "p" de largo o sea que esto mide
"p" y mide 2r de ancho entonces esto de aquí mide 2r.
Entonces cuál será su área, su área cuando tenemos un rectángulo el área de ese rectángulo
siempre es base por altura.
Entonces esta área, toda esta área va a ser igual a 2r por "p"
2rp.
La otra cosa que tenemos que sacar es, cuál es el área de un círculo cuyo diámetro mide 4r.
Entonces dibujemos por aquí un círculo ahí está más o menos nuestro círculo y nos dicen que su diámetro
mide 4r ¿Ok?.
Más o menos esto de aquí es su diámetro y esta línea realmente está a la mitad de este círculo.
Entonces su centro está por aquí ¿Ok? Entonces
todo esto mide
4r y ¿Cómo se le hace para sacar el área de un círculo?
Pues nosotros tenemos la fórmula de geometría que nos dice que el área de un círculo
el área del círculo es igual a pi por radio al cuadrado ¿Ok?.
Ahora aquí hay que tener mucho cuidado
está "r" no es la misma "r" que está "r", o que está "r" de hecho, aquí sería bueno escribir algo así como
radio para que no se confundan las variables.
Claro que muchas veces cuando estás trabajando en álgebra te vas a encontrar con
ejercicios que usan la misma variable que tú estás usando para alguna otra fórmula
entonces, es un muy buen ejercicio ese de reconocer qué variables son la fórmula,
y qué variable son de tu ejercicio, y que realmente aunque sean la misma letra no tienen nada que ver.
Entonces pues vamos a quitarle sus letras.
Entonces ahorita lo que tenemos que averiguar es cuánto vale
esta "r" ¿Ok? Cuánto vale el radio que no es esta "r", el radio es esta distancia
que es exactamente la mitad del diámetro.
¿Ok? La mitad de 4r así es que este radio mide 2r.
¿Ok? Entonces el área de este círculo es igual a pi y por nuestro radio que es 2r,
este radio al cuadrado ¿Ok? El radio
mide exactamente 2r ya pensé que pues ni modo le vamos a dejar
todas las letras en la palabra radio pero bueno esto se puede simplificar y nos queda que él área
es igual a 2r por 2r es igual a 4r al cuadrado.
Entonces esta área la vamos a escribir como 4
pi por "r" al cuadrado
donde está "r" no es de radio es de la "r" que nos dieron,
¿Ok? Nada más se le ve este término al cuadrado y lo reacomodé para que las constantes queden de lado izquierdo.
Ahora queremos encontrar la diferencia,
y la forma de hacer eso es tomar la resta de cualesquiera de estas dos áreas y luego sacar el valor absoluto
pero, si no queremos poner por ahí el valor absoluto pues mejor averigüemos cuál de estas 2 áreas es más grande que la otra,
y entonces ya nada más restamos a la más grande la más chica y ya encontramos la
diferencia ¿Ok? Y para eso lo que vamos a usar es esta cosa que nos dieron por aquí,
que dice que "p" es más grande que 7r, "p" es más grande que
7r y ¿Cómo vamos a usar eso? Pues vamos a multiplicar los 2 lados de la desigualdad por
2r y eso no debería de cambiar esta desigualdad ¿Ok? Por que 2r
tiene que ser mayor que 0 por que es cuánto mide el ancho del rectángulo,
y estamos hablando de rectángulos no degenerados,
o sea de rectángulos normales en los cuales pues el ancho tiene que ser mayor que 0.
Entonces no se nos voltea este signo de igual que estamos multiplicando por 2r
y nos queda igual a 7 por 2, 14r
cuadrada ¿Ok? 2rp es mayor que
14r cuadrada ahora ¿Para que hice eso de multiplicar por 2r? Pues por que entonces
esto de aquí es
exactamente igual al área del rectángulo
¿Ok? Área del rectángulo
y esto de aquí, aunque todavía no es claro
tiene mucho que ver con el área de este círculo, de hecho es mayor que el área del círculo
¿Ok? Pero está, esa relación la tenemos que sacar con todo cuidado.
Tenemos por aquí 4pi por "r" al cuadrado
y cuánto vale pi pues pi vale
3.1415926535 bla, bla, bla una infinidad de decimales a la derecha
pero, tú no te tienes que aprender todo eso que hay generalmente se redondea como pi igual a
3.1416
en lugar de 3.1415926535 y bla, bla, bla  pero,
resulta que
14 lo podemos escribir como
4 por 3.5
¿Ok? Tal vez debería de describir un paréntesis por aquí este es un punto decimal y este es un punto de que se están multiplicando
y pues pi como es 3.1416
definitivamente es más chico que 3.5.
¿Ok? Esto es mayor que
4 por pi,
entonces lo que tenemos es que el área del círculo, área el círculo,
que es igual a 4 por pi por "r" al cuadrado
otra vez "r" tiene que ser mayor que 0
entonces en esta desigualdad podemos multiplicar
de los dos lados por "r" al cuadrado y es mayor que 0 entonces, no se voltea esta desigualdad.
Entonces esto es menor estricto a 4 por 3.5
eso es por esta desigualdad de aquí pero, pues 4 por 3.5 es 14 entonces podemos poner
14 por "r" al cuadrado
"r" al cuadrado
esta desigualdad es tal cual, simplemente multiplicar por "r" al cuadrado de los 2 lados de esta desigualdad.
¿Ok? Pero esto de aquí ya es
exactamente igual a esto entonces,
14r al cuadrado termino siendo mayor que
4 por pi por "r" al cuadrado
que es el área del círculo.
Entonces el área del rectángulo es más grande que el área del círculo.
Si ésta "p" es más grande que 7 veces esta "r" y entonces para expresar como un binomio
como un binomio
la diferencia entre estas 2 áreas, vamos a tomar esta área que es la más grande que es 2r por "p"
y le vamos a restar el área de este círculo que es
4 por pi por "r" al cuadrado.
Y ya terminamos.